okay continuing our break from the
horrible news for something funny very
briefly I was contacted early during my
vacation by famous birthdays calm and
they said hey we're putting together a
page for you David Pakman is going to
have a famous birthdays calm page is
that okay with you I said that sounds
fine they said will you give us a
release to pull pictures from social
media of you so that we can put them on
the page and I said that sounds great
and they said no problem we are going to
be ranking your popularity across
various categories and the page will be
up soon and I said this is going to be
good so I have now appeared and ranked
and I'm ready to make a huge huge
announcement
I am the fifty-four thousand four
hundred and twenty second most popular
person on famous birthdays calm most
interestingly this is the great
cross-section of rankings
I'm the 18th most popular 34 year old TV
show host
I'm the 23rd most popular aquarius named
David and I'm the fourth most popular TV
show host born in Argentina behind Belen
Rodriguez Marcella T Nelly and Susan
Jimenez who I was shocked to find out by
the way 74 years of age now I don't know
which is more notable I think that
fourth most popular Argentinian TV show
host is is probably it now of course in
Argentina there are way more than three
other TV hosts that are more popular
than me in Argentina I think that famous
birthdays calm is talking about
popularity in the United States and they
think that because the show is us-based
and a majority of our audience is from
the US it explains that anyway
apparently you can help boost my
popularity on famous birthdays calm by
going to the page my page there and
clicking the boost button I believe that
it's free I don't really know how it
works it would be great to crack the top
25,000 on
famous birthdays calm if you want to see
this link in the YouTube description it
is famous birthdays calm / people /
David - pakman.com should I care about
this or is this really dumb I'm not sure
you can let me know on on Twitter at de
Pakman